حاميه في مجلس العمومي البريطاني مره اخرى
الهجره موضوعها
رئيس الوزراء كان جزءا من ثلاث حكومات
تعهدت بخفض الهجره ولكنها في كل مره لم
تفي بذلك فلماذا يعتقد ان وزيره داخليته
فشلت في التعامل مع نظام النقاط
الاسرائيلي الدفاع عن سياسه حكومته ويتهم
المعارضه بالافتقار الى سياسه واضحه
لمعالجه هذه القضيه الشائكه
وهذه جلسه اخرى لكنها طارئه يعترف وزير
الهجره خلالها بان الارقام عاليه ويتعهد
بخفضها
الهجره عاليه جدا والحكومه ملتزمه بخفضها
لمستويات المستدامه والحكومه طرحت نظام
النقاط قبل ثلاثه اعوام لاستعاده السيطره
على الحدود بعد علينا الان تحديد من ياتي
الى بريطانيا وتنفيذ نظام يعكس المتطلبات
المتغيره لسوق العمل
بيانات مكتب الاحصاءات الوطنيه اظهرت
ارتفاعا في مستوى الهجره في البلاد عام
2022 بما يزيد على نصف مليون مهاجر اي
بنسبه 20% مقارنه بعام 2021
المكتب عزا الاسباب الى زياده تاشيرات
العمل فالبلاد عانت في السنوات الاخيره من
نقص حاد في العماله الماهره وذوي الخبرات
علاوه على زياده تاشيرات الحالات
الانسانيه لا سيما من افغانستان واوكرانيا
وهونج كونج تشير الارقام الرسميه ايضا الى
زياده في عدد الطلبه الاجانب ومرافقيهم في
بريطانيا بنسبه 76% خلال الاعوام الخمسه
الماضيه زياده سبقتها وزيره الداخليه بفرض
قيود على الطلبه الاجانب في محاوله اخرى
للتعامل مع الهجره
فالخطه الجديده تمنع الطلبه الاجانب من
مرافقه عائلاتهم باستثناء الطلبه الابحاث
ومن العمل قبل انهاء الدراسه رغم ان الراي
العام البريطاني لا ينظر الى هؤلاء
كمهاجرين
عامه ينظرون الى الطلبه كمهاجرين ومن وجهه
نظرنا يجب ان لا نضعهم في خانه المهاجرين
لانهم يساهمون بشكل كبير في اقتصاد البلاد
بدقه 42 مليار جنيه فيه حسب دراسه
اجريناها الاسبوع الماضي
ومعهم سياسيون محافظون يرون ان الوزيره
تطمح في الوصول الى السلطه من خلال لهجتها
التي اعتبروها معاديه للمهاجرين من حرب
الجزيره لندن